the most recent lesson we did which was
talking about always it talking about -
remember we were comparing sizes of sets
weren't we right yeah what you made is
we were comparing the integers with the
rationals with the reals and drawing
some unusual conclusions okay now I
noticed some of you right now your
brains kind of and in fact some of you
disagree with some of the like tie
methods I showed you I just want to go
on record to say that I think both of
those things are good okay
um number one your brain hurts I think
it's good that your brain hurts if when
you're considering all of this stuff
right and you're noticing there's
different kinds of infinity right like
our brains don't deal with infinity well
we've made a lot of big things in the
universe large numbers but we never
really encounter an finish so it's no
surprise that if you are really
wrestling with these ideas you start to
get a bit of a headache actually if
you're probably not getting a bit of a
headache you're probably not thinking
hard okay so I think that's a good thing
secondly if you disagree and I saw
people were posting they're like nah
it's garbage totally disagree I think
it's a rubbish proof okay
I also do that's good because if you
think back to last Friday right what
last Friday was about do you remember we
talked about how important disagree with
use okay
actually when there's disagreement when
you make progress and you know things
like say on negative numbers or
irrational numbers or was the other ones
can say imaginary numbers right all of
these when they were first proposed by
some crazy mathematician who thought I'm
just going to break the rules and see
what happens right they all sparked
incredible disagreements okay but I
think that's good
I've got this quote I was from one of my
favorite authors you might know him as
the person who wrote The Chronicles of
Narnia you did a few other things as
well but that's those popular
is done I he wrote this but we find
difficulty we may always expect that a
discovery awaits us you can see where he
would lie or discovery invention where
there is cover we hope for game he means
in terms of like hunting a game hunting
like you know you don't go looking in
wide open spaces where things are easy
to go and find interesting unusual
things you're going to look where it's
hard you're going to look in like a cave
or underneath like where there's trees
and shrubs where there's places for
things to hide that's where you make the
really interesting discoveries ok and
today we're going to look at another one
of those unusual ideas that raise all
the rules namely division by zero now
many of you have wanted to tackle this
ok which has been I'm really glad that
so many of your enthusiastic to do it
but it's a tricky idea it's a shitty
idea for a lot of reasons there's a lot
of assumptions that go into what you
think this isn't what you think it means
ok so to help you get into this I'm
going to pose a couple of questions to
you ok
first one's not retired cool um when it
comes to matter that are like science
type stuff ok what's the basic building
block of matter what's the basic
building now the first aids are and this
is sort of early early 20th century I
think the first answer was atoms ok in
fact even the name out of this anyone
know an atom means it's a Greek word
what comes from a Greek website it comes
from well that a a means you know when
you put a in front of a word like
asymmetric or atheist or what does it
mean it may a means generally means not
I took a symmetrical not not symmetrical
so a means not and this word comes from
the Greek word for cut or divide right
so you can't you can't chop it up you
can't divide it it's indivisible that's
that's kind of um that's kind of frozen
yet
except up in the arm in the 20s and 30s
thanks to Einstein we discovered
actually they kind of are divisible with
some with some pretty disastrous sorts
of arm at cetera my friend this is this
is my mushroom cloud okay um
Weesa pretty disastrous consequences
right atoms can be divided I'm gonna I'm
gonna rub that up for the test yeah when
you divide it out and what do you get
you get subatomic particles like before
we get there I get electrons you get
protons and what was the other one
neutrons good so like we have good
reason to not think there's anything
below this because we can't see these
kinds of things right these are too
small to see with eyes you can get a
really really big microscope and you're
starting to get towards like the
wavelength of light right so can't see
him but we know that they're there they
can pre proved experimentally but then
someone with a bigger machine and more
of a research budget to decide to say
well is this as far as it can go and you
can go further right what do you get you
get quacks I'm like and leptons and and
bruise ons like the famous Higgs boson
right well uh this isn't a scientist so
I'm not gonna get too far into but
suffice to say these things actually
we're only triggered on it are they on
this level I think I don't know this is
getting out my deaf now okay but here's
the point we thought these are the small
things that you could get everything was
good to these but you're like no no this
smaller stuff there's smaller stuff and
then this theories about like what these
are they're strings that are vibrating
or whatever okay but I think this is as
far as we've got at the moment that make
sense so come in
- Nikita Nikita homes with Jonah come up
Nikita who an X here and anyone else
that's all okay now
ready here's where we bring this home to
us
and where we're going today okay now I'm
going to ask you this question
I don't you shout out in the answers
just want you to think about it think
about what you think your answer would
be and I also want you to think about
just like here how do you justify your
answer if someone else came up with a
different answer to you how would you
convince them no no the answer is this
because so you think of what you're
introducing and think of why right so my
first question was what was the basic
building block of matter my next
question is what's the basic building
block of maths I want you to think about
it see if you can come up with an answer
in your head maybe this put that go back
and forth if you think you can settle on
an odd side do you think you explain why
that's the answer
okay now I'll give you about 10 more
seconds to think about this I am so
confident that I know what most of your
answer will be that I'm going to get you
- all we've done this before shout it
out at the same time okay I'll be really
interested to see if there's more than
one answer here okay I'm reasonably
coughing you all have the same ISM okay
so again three I go one two three go
okay and then I'm going to ask you to
also at the same time are you ready yeah
you really want more time I'll give you
another 30 seconds
yeah I think you should be able to if
you if your answer is more than one word
I'm okay with that if you think you know
why and I want to know what you think
not beatniks boring your answer doesn't
count anymore okay all right so the
question was what's the basic building
block of maths right this is the
basically won't matter everything that's
made up of stuff is made up of these
okay what is it formats are you ready
okay one two three okay
all right hold on now I think the most
comment I heard was the answer I was
expecting which was numbers hands up who
said numbers okay that that is most of
you if you don't know you can hit
perchance down who who said something
different what else do we have yep
that's interested but it's not
necessarily part of it anyway I won't
get into it okay we made it and we got
we wouldn't be okay
I can't I'll give that up I'll give that
a question well I'm not sure where I
stand of that one different answers oh
okay all right so hold on hold on so
I've got I've got numbers that was by
fun that was by far the most common
answer okay I had I had quacks okay I
had I've symbols
who's got different a top zero zero so
you say a number is that yeah okay yeah
yeah I don't know if you can really say
an event an event is a basic building
okay lost lucky okay so I guess okay all
right now here's the thing if we went
out on the street and we went and
conducted the same experiment okay I
think we would probably get the same
kind of representation of this being the
most common answer and you can kinda you
can't play games these kinds of things
but in terms of like what we normally
think of the mass I think numbers is a
reasonable response okay it's certainly
when I thought my response would be
but people way smarter than me and
eventually me when I was convincing us
all the arguments disagree they say no
no no this is not it
and the reason why I actually have comes
to what Brennan said because numbers
right numbers are really just symbols
they're just labels that we've put on
this right
there's actually something much deeper
than the numbers and I'll show you what
I mean okay um I should write one up
first uh something like say three that's
a number but what is three just like
with these right you'll like okay
numbers are like atoms but can you dig
any further into that and find anything
else and I think can write because
passed a label like if you we're trying
to explain to like a very very young
child okay because young children learn
to low numbers very very quickly
what would you say three is like if you
said okay okay
a cat is and then you're like here's cat
okay right and you know um a car is a
menu like there's a car okay and then
you say three gears and what would you
say and they're like but what's that now
I actually think it's it's not that hard
I think we would mostly do the same
thing I think we would say um yeah this
is three look see one two three and
they'll be like well this is whiteboard
markers right so go away right right
this is three in the same way look
that um hello hold these up that these
are through I even had the same colors
that's convenient okay look I know you
see these a wipe or markers and these
are you don't toys cubes whatever but
the thing that they have in common right
and the things that they have in common
with say you know these right the theme
equality the actually that they share
that's what three is right in fact so
what we got is right what I've got is
hope it under here okay I've got I've
got white blood markers I've got these
these cube things people and what was my
last thing I'll comes to cry three is
what this all have in common there hold
on a second hold on a second we have
language for this we just spent like a
good week and a half or two weeks
developing what the language but these
things are what are these these are sets
our thing these are sense that's what
they are well done okay
they're sets of while the elements in
this set are cups and the elements in
this set are you get the idea you go way
back to what our definition for a set
was it's a collection of objects we call
them elements so therefore deeper than
numbers are sets that's what this is
really about
okay and then everything everything
flows from that for instance for
instance what is what is two plus three
sips something simple like that okay now
you say you say well it's five right but
why is it five and I'll tell you why you
take a set of two things and you take a
set of three things and when you put
them together you have a new set of five
things right okay well well how about
I'm running out of hands how about four
minus one what is four minus one well I
can't we know what for
but why does 4-1 that what does that
mean in terms of all this it means you
have a set of four things right you have
a set of four things and you take away a
set which has one thing and that leaves
you with a set there's three things in
them right so it all comes down to these
guys and about counting them and that's
when you get operations when set into
racked ah okay now here's the
interesting thing
right it starts with all of this
counting of concrete things concrete
things but then we can say well
overweight right we can do things like
this without actually having the things
in front of us right because we can
develop rules for how this works
for instance if you have a set of some
size and you take away a set which has
the same size then doesn't that you
don't need to know how big the sets are
this was like a paring thing yesterday
you can say you have an empty set at the
end right or the same way if you have a
set and then you take away or if you
take away a set that's bigger it means
you kind of have a set which is well
it's it's not there right it's like I'm
short one there's one that I can't take
away are missing one okay and you can
rearrange it so you can see how it works
okay I mean you know I I would get this
line from the line like this so you're
aware if I added five to both sides
right it's internally consistent it
makes sense this is something I can
picture with whiteboard markers and I
can extend to something that I can't
picture but it makes sense I get one
from the other
okay so this is what edition is it's
pretty sets together this is what
subtraction is taking sets apart okay
I'm going to ask you to write a couple
of sentences on second addition
subtraction in this scheme what would
multiplication and division bit because
you can see you can see where I'm
heading right but I need you to go back
and think about these old ideas you
you've known them for so long that
you've forgotten why do I believe these
things and why do they
mean what they mean like I can do
multiplication I can do division but why
are they that so I'm going to give you a
couple minutes I want you to write out
percentage multiplication is division is
right and try to fit it in this scheme
of what mathematics is really about I'll
give you a couple minutes to have a book
about it